I think it will be fitting if you begin
Dr. Zakia by explaining the term once
again for our viewers for the benefit of
the viewers and myself. Uh what does
exactly mean and what does it signify
for the Muslims? Alhamdulillah.
The meaning of the word
means night. Kad means decree or power
or high esteem or majesty. So means
night of power or night of decree or
knight of majesty or night of high
esteem. And as far as the virtues of
leak is concerned, it is one of the best
nights in the month of Ramadan. Rather,
it is the best night in the full year.
And this was the night in which the
Quran was revealed. And Allah subhanaa
tala says in the Quran
in surah chapter number 97 verse number
1 to5
which means that indeed we have revealed
this message that is the Quran in the
night of power in the night of decree
and what will explain to thee what is
the night of power the night of power is
better than a thousand months.
Therein the spirit and the angels they
descend with the permission of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala at every end. Peace
this until mourn. So from this verse of
the Quran we come to know that this
night of the night of power the night of
decree is the best night in the full
year. And this was a night in which the
Quran was revealed. And it further says
that this night is of power, of majesty,
of high esteem and of dignity. And any
good deed that is done in this night is
better than what is done in a thousand
months. And if you divide, thousand
months by 12, it comes to more than 83
years. And that is much more than the
average life of a human being. So if you
do worship in this one night, it is
better than doing worship for your full
life. And further it says that this is
the night when the angels and their
spirit they descend down with the
permission of Allah subhana wa t'ala.
And in this night there is peace till
morning. And further it's mentioned in
the Quran in surah dukan chapter number
44 verse number 3 and 4 that we have
revealed the message the glorious Quran
in this blessed night and we warn you
from the evil and in it we ordain what
has been decreed and this night
also means measurement
and it's mentioned in the Quran in surah
chapter number 54
verse number 49 that verily we have
created all things in due proportion and
measure.
So
also means somewhat like it's a night of
decree when Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
sends down the decree
the
what is going to happen in the full year
from this to next that is the reason a
beloved prophet wasallam said it's
mentioned in say bkari
volume number three in the Book of
superiority of light through Hadit
number 2014 that anyone who prays in the
night of Kadar with faith and seeking
Allah's reward all his past sins will be
forgiven. So these are the virtues of
the night of Kadar.